des fortunes sont investis présentement
à travers le globe pour trouver le
remède miracle
l'université dalhousie en nouvelle
écosse marque le pas des essais
cliniques seront menés sur une centaine
de cobayes de 18 à 55 ans pour avoir des
effets secondaires la raison justement
qu'on veut tester un produit composé qui
pourraient avoir des propriétés baissé
de vérifier justement si dans une
certaine groupe d'individus soudainement
des effets ne se ramène à ce moment
justement évidemment dans le creux de
2009 on les connait trés nié ces faits
là les volontaires qui participent à
cette recherche scientifique seront
suivis de près par des professionnels de
la santé pour s'assurer qu'il n'y ait
pas d'effets secondaires
même si ce sont les vaccins qui attire
l'attention
la solution dans l'immédiat et peut-être
ailleurs dans les médicaments selon
certains experts il n'y a pas simplement
le vaccin est aussi des produits
antiviraux parce qu'on dépasse certes à
scientifiquement
si un vaccin va fonctionner même si ça
va fonctionner est ce qu'on va le
développer rapidement
là on devra pas simplement à mettre tout
notre argent tout notre nous ressources
dans le développement d'un vaccin mais
également d'autres produits
et même si un vaccin est trouvé il
faudra être patient avant qu'il soit
accessible
les essais cliniques pourrait prendre
des années tout comme la production mais
le coût qui ont démontré une maintenant
que c'est très efficace puisque chaque
round bon ça il faut le produire ce
vaccin là alors on le produit ou parce
que sont pas équipés halifax produits
les vaccins et 9 00 production oracle
alors il faut les changer d'axé l'eau il
existe très peu d'entreprises dans le
monde qui ont la capacité de produire
des centaines de millions de vaccins
la coalition pour l'innovation de la
préparation contre les épidémies un
regroupement de plusieurs pays dont le
canada a récolté 915 millions de dollars
de dons privés sur les 2 milliards
nécessaires pour accélérer les tests et
la construction d'usinés spécialisées
ici marie michel lauzon radio-canada à
montréal